celebrate one sign come on we got one
time just passable and chess.com oh no
oh
hey officer
hi sir I have talked to you about this
many times do it now now it's okay you
may not be advertising checks.com
adjustable together at the same time I
told you there's one sign sir you may
not be advertising chess.com accessible
at the same time please give me the side
yeah I don't want to give me the sign of
them okay no you can't do anything
it's all the world everybody put your
hands behind your back you have the
right to move one square at a time
if it is your very first move you may
move two squares at a time but yeah go
backwards you have the right when you
have reached the eighth rank to consult
with a promotional officer about your
future I want to be a queen just come
with me to the back of the corner that's
gonna be a queen
okay go backwards I can't move backwards
[Music]
foreign
the way
[Music]